صباحنا اليوم نسائي بامتياز حيث يجتمع
العالم لقول صباح الخير لكل نساء العالم
بمناسبه يوم المراه العالمي الذي يصادف
الثامن من شهر مارس لكل عام المراه التي
ما زالت تبحث عن المساواه تبدو امام واقع
صعب يؤكد فيه الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو بوتيريش اسفا ان المساواه
الحقيقيه بين الرجل والمراه هدف بعيد
المنال ويحتاج نحو 300 عام على اقل تقدير
لتحقيقه ورغم ذلك فان الامم المتحده تبحث
عن الجديد الذي يقرب المراه من المساواه
وهذا العام يبدو الابتكار والتكنولوجيا
احد اهم الطرق من اجل المساواه بين
الجنسين والامل في ان يكون تمكين النساء
تكنولوجيا سبيلا لمساواه اكبر حيث فتحت
اعمال الدوره 67 لجنه وضع المراه مركزه
على الابتكار والتغيير التكنولوجي
والتعليم الرقمي لتعزيز سد الفجوه بين
الجنسين
[موسيقى]
وفي تغطيتنا الخاصه مع مراسلات صباح
العربيه للحديث عن المراه في يومها
العالمي تنضم الينا كل من جانب المشاط من
بغداد ناجح حجازي من القاهره سوهاج من
عمان هند ابراهيم من واشنطن اهلا بكم
جميعا كل عام وانتم بالف خير ابدا معك
زينب اهلا بك زينب كل عام وانت بالف خير
صباح الخير وكل عام وانتم بالف خير المراه
طبعا مثل المطر ما تنتظر شكر ولا عرفان
يعني المطر اذا نزل لا ينتظر لا شكر ولا
عرفان بطله اليوم من العراق يا رينو
الجافي اول امراه عراقيه تقود طائره حربيه
رينو انتشرت عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
في نوفمبر 2022
بعد ان حصلت على اجازه قياده طائره حربيه
بعد 150 ساعه من التحليق في الجو وهي اول
امراه بالعراق تقض طائره حربيه منذ عام
1949 في عام 1949 كانت اول امراه حصلت على
قياده طائره مدنيه وليست عسكريه جوزيف
حداد بعد 73 ساعه من الطيران طبعا رينو
واجهت الكثير من المصاعب النفسيه
والاجتماعيه تحدثت عنها خلال مشوارها في
هذا المجال يعني المجال العسكري اليوم
الكثير من النساء في العراق يعني
استطاعوا ان ينضموا الى السلك العسكري
سواء في اقليم او في المركز المركز
العاصمه بغداد طبعا انا اظهر اليوم من عند
انتاج شهريار وشهرزاد عن قصدير لانه هذا
التمثال الذي هو خلفي تمثال هو اول تمثال
اعطى درس
للعالم كله بان المراه القادره على ترويض
رجل وصف بصفاح النساء مثل شهريار هي قادره
على فعل اي شيء في المستقبل نعم وكل عام
وانتم بالف خير يا سهام ونادين
زميلاتهم مراسلات كذلك يسعد لي صباحك يا
زينب وصباح كل مراسلات صباح العربيه ونحن
مستمرون مع مراسلات صباح العربيه نذهب
معكم الى مصر ففي كل بلد هناك عينات
ونماذج كثيره من النساء اللواتي تركن بصمه
في هذه الدنيا ويتركن وايضا هم قدوه لجيل
المستقبل وابناء اليوم ندى حجازي ستعرفنا
ربما على اول سائقه مترو في مصر عندما
كانت هذه المهنه حكرا على الرجال المراه
تريد والمراه تستطيع ان تستطيع ان تحلم
اليك يا ندى
صباح الخير نادين صباح الخير سهام في
الحقيقه السيدات المصريات حققوا انجازات
كتير خلال الفتره اللي فاتت فاحنا عندنا
الاول مره المراه المصريه بتجلس على منصه
المحكمه بمجلس الدوله واول مره المراه
المصريه تمثل النيابه العامه امام محكمه
الجنايات وكمان لاول مره المترو بقياده
نسائيه زي ما حكيتوا عشان كده انا اخترت
النهارده محطه المترو تكون خلفيتي في البث
ده وانا دايما بسعد باقتحام النساء
لمجالات كانت حكر على الرجال فكل عام
والمراه المصريه والعربيه والعالميه تحقق
احلامها بحريه دون قيود من المراه المصريه
للمراه الاردنيه هذه المره مع سها جميل
يسعد صباحك يسوع كل عام وانت بالف خير
اهلا بك
صباح الخير بدايه ما اجمل صباح العربيه
عندما تقدمه سيدتين جميلتين وهذا ما ينطبق
على كل ما تقدمه المراه
كل عام وجميع النساء بالف خير قصتي عن
الحاضره الغائبه السيده اسماء خضر التي
تستحق اليوم ذكرى في هذا يوم المراه
العالمي رحلت في عام 2021 وهي ناشطه
حقوقيه اضافه الى انها سياسيه اردنيه شغلت
الكثير من المناصب منها كانت وزيره
للاعلام اضافه الى انها كانت عضو في مجلس
الاعيان وكانت وزيره للثقافه مرتين
متتاليتين لكنها ايضا ناشطه حقوقيه محاميه
في معهد تضامن النسائي الاردني نادت بحقوق
المراه وما زال هذا المعهد يعمل كانت ضد
زواج الفتيات في عمر مبكر كانت ضد اعفاء
الرجل المختصب في حاله تزوجه من الضحيه
بان يعفى من العقاب كانت تنادي بالتج
ابناء الاردنيات وكانت تحمل كثير من
السيدات من خلال دعوه ما يعرف بجرائم
الشرف اسمى خضر استمرت في هذا العمل
لسنوات في معهد تضامن كانت تعمل على تمكين
المراه اقتصاديا واجتماعيا كانت تبحث عن
فرص للحياه للمراه وما زال هذا المعهد
يعمل بنفس الراحله اسمى خضر وكانت هناك
العديد من اللقاءات لهذه السيده وكانت
يعني تحمي العديد من السيدات بدعوى يعني
الهروب من جرائم الشرف وقد شهدت الكثير من
قصص النجاح لسيدات في الارياف وفي الباديه
وحتى في مجتمعاتنا الحضريه والمدنيه لانها
كانت دائما تنادي بالمساواه التي ما زالت
نساء العالم ايضا تنادي بها حتى هذه
اللحظه على كل حال سهانه سعيده جدا بهذا
اللايف بالسداسي الذي يجمعنا كنساء على
الهواء مباشره في يوم المراه العالمي
سباعي عم بيقولوا لي بس كمان خلينا نروح
لواشن ولا هند ابراهيم هند باليوم المراه
العالمي اول شغله تسمحي لي اني ارحب فيك
وهاي لاول مره هند معانا مباشره في صباح
العربيه وجها لوجه بنتقابل معاك اهلا
وسهلا فيك في فريق صباح العربيه هند
سمعتوا على تقارير هند طوال الفتره
الماضيه هذا اولا وثانيا هند اليوم المراه
العالمي بدا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ماذا تقولين في هذا اليوم
اولا صباح الخير سهام ونادين وكل عام
وانتم وجميع مشاهداتنا ونساء العالم بالف
خير
وبهذه المناسبه ساتحدث لكم عن المراه
الاكثر اثاره في عالم التكنولوجيا ميرا
موراتي وميرا تبلغ من العمر 35 عاما فقط
لكنها كبيره المسؤولين التكنولوجيين في
شركه اوبن اي اي الشركه المسؤوله عن تطوير
الروبات الذكاء الاصطناعي شات الذي اكتسح
العالم مؤخرا وكنا قد غطينا هذا الموضوع
في السابق
ميرال تخرجت عام 2012
بكالوريوس بالهندسه ومنذ ذلك الحين والى
الان وهي تقود فرق في اهم الشركات
التكنولوجيه العالميه منها شركه تسلا حيث
عملت لمده ثلاث سنوات تحديدا لتطوير طراز
اكس مو هذه السياره الكهربائيه ثم انتقلت
للعمل مع شركه ليب موشن وكان املها ان
تلغي الكيبورد من الكمبيوتر او
اللوح لوحه المفاتيح املا بان تجعل
الكمبيوتر علاقته بالناس وكانت قد تحدثت
انا قالت انها تامل يتعمل الناس مع
الكمبيوتر كانهم يلعبون كره القدم واخيرا
في عام 2018
انضمت الى شركه اوبن اي اي حينها كانت
الشركه
30075 موظف فقط وهي كانت شركه ناشئه لكن
بعمل ميرا موراتي تحولت هذه الشركه الان
الى شركه تقدر ارادتها ب 30 مليار دولار
عالميا وطبعا وهناك اكثر من 100 مليون
مستخدم لرشات جي بي تي شهريا وهي ايضا
تعمل على
وهو ايضا ذكاء لكن يمكن ان يقوم باعمال
فنيه من الممكن ان ينشا لوحات وتماثيل
والى اخره من التصميمات
نرى ايضا انتقلت كمان لانه لسه الساعتين
طوال للاحتفال بيوم المراه العالمي
والمراه امام الذكاء الاصطناعي لديها ذكاء
اجتماعي فانا اشكركم جزيل الشكر من واشنطن
هند ابراهيم اشكر ايضا مدحجازي من القاهره
واشكر ايضا زينب المشاط من بغداد وسها
جميل من عمان شكرا لكلنا